et avec nous donc les deux héros du film
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous honneur
aux dames comme on dit en France bonsoir
reneleger est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire les choses avec sincérité ce soir
puisquon est entre nous comment il est
le George Cloney réalisateur
dur oh il est il est
épouventable oh non
non c'est vrai directur je suis
F
oui s'imposé il a de de l'autorité mais
il y a longtemps que nous travaillons
ensemble
et moi je savais qu'il ferait un très
bon film et je ne savais pas que ce
serait avec tant de connaissance de tout
le processus parce que c'est il faut
savoir beaucoup de choses en même temps
il
faut dominer énormément de sujets
surtout pour un film comme celui-ci je
crois que ça s'est bien passé n
pas
ou merci je
je prendrai ca en EUR s'il vous plaît
alors geor cl pourquoi ce choix de
l'Amérique des années 20 de ce football
américain qui nît et et ce rapport entre
le business qui arrive dans le football
pourquoi ce choix c'est un choix que
vous aviez depuis quelques années je
crois
oui enfin disons qu'il y avait un
scénario depuis quelques années sur
lequel j'avais envie de travailler je
venais de
terminer un certain nombre de films
comme good night and good
luckana bon il y avait c'était des films
des films un peu politiques là je
voulais un film avec un happy end un
film un peu plus léger plus agréable
plus marrant essentiellement et si on
est étiqueté dans les films politiqu
c'est tout ce qu'on vous laisse faire on
est stéréotypé alors j'ai dit je fais
autre chose là c'est une comédie
romantique on sait comment elle se
termine c'est toujours agréable et on
voulait que le le monde se termine mieux
à la fin du film et c'était ça une façon
de le faire Ren zeger vous incarnez une
journaliste qui un scoop qui détient un
scoop et qui va finir par le
diffuser comment il va vous a présenter
ce rôle de cette journaliste un petit
peu séductrice il vous a présenté
comment ce ce
rôle
ah euh
oui un peu comme vous dites il un petit
peu de tout
et c'étaitelle la meilleure cette
journaliste elle est intelligente elle
est jolie
alors rassure-toi et puis après il m'a
montré quelquesunes des des comédies
loufoc qu'il aime beaucoup et on a
essayé de s'inspirer
ait que cette cette confiance et voilà
l'autre c'est vrai que c'est toujours
utile de de de se comparer au aux
antérieurs et puis les imiter un petit
peu ça fait pas de mal alors George
Cloun c'est un métier qui vous aurait
plusu journaliste justement je crois que
vous avez commencé des études de
journaliste c'est là que vous vient
cette idée
de alors c'est vrai que j'ai fait des
études de
journalisme mais c'était plutôt un hobby
je faisais ça quand j'étais étudiant
c'est pour ça également oui c'est vrai
c'est vrai cela étant bon c'est toujours
en hommage à mon père ce que je fais
c'està dire que y même good night and
good luck cétait un hommage à à la
carrière de de mon père et un hommage au
respect que j'ai pour pour le
journalisme mais là c'était quelque
chose de plus léger de plus amusant on
parle de la façon dont on crée des héros
moi je trouve ça un peu inquiétant
d'ailleurs Ren zelveeger est-ce que
c'est dur de de se détacher quand on
fait ce métier des étiquettes vous avez
été pendant des années Bridget Jones
est-ce que c'est dur de se détacher de
ces rôles qui sont très importants très
forts qui vous ont rendu extrêmement
connu dans le
entier vous savez je n'y pense plus
vraiment franchement ce personnage
c'était quelque chose dans ma vie c'est
vrai
que cela m'a beaucoup influencé je je ne
le Renis pas je rencontre encore des
personnes qui s'y réfèrent mais
cependant je ne pense pas que je sois
mise entièrement dans cette petite boîte
la boîte de Bridget Jones je pense que
c'était un très bon
et que j'ai toutes sortes d'autres
possibilités j'en ai eu beaucoup j'ai
beaucoup d'autres rôles aussi il y en a
d'autres à qui on dit tout le temps wat
c'est effectivement une formule que vous
devez entendre tout le temps tout le
temps en ce moment je voulais qu'on
revienne sur effectivement votre
engagement également George clouny vous
parliez de votre père il y a un instant
on vous a vu au darrefour on vous a vu à
l'ONU est-ce que cet engagement vous
avez été sur le terrain concrètement
est-ce que vous pensez que vous vous
pouvez faire avancer le dossier est-ce
que vous pouvez faire changer les chose
ou faire prendre simplement conscience
déjà au monde et c'est déjà ça qui est
important je ne pense pas que je puisse
changer le monde en tout cas
individuellement on peut pas y arriver
tout seul mais ensemble on peut faire
bouger un petit peu ce que je peux faire
seul c'est mettre en quelque sorte
l'éclairage sur des des grands problèmes
du monde et effectivement faire prendre
conscience au monde de certaines réalité
le monde est dur en ce moment le monde
est dur vous savez que on voit toujours
dans l'actualité des chose épouvantable
et quelquefois l'actualité se perd parce
que il y a toujours quelque chose qui
vient
remplacer les nouvelles il y a toujours
quelque chose d'autres il est difficile
de rester concentré sur un seul et même
dossier donc notre responsabilité c'est
de veiller à ce que ces choses restent
d'actualité alors c'est l'une des
questions du moment aux États-Unis je
suis obligé de vous la poser tout de
même qui selon vous de Hillary Clinton
Barack Obama ou monsieur John McCain
aura on va dire le regard le plus
éclairé sur la planète dans les années à
venir
le regard le plus éclairé sur la planète
moi ce que je dirais ce serait Brad Pitt
qui serait peut-être le mieux placé pour
pour le job cela étant ça fait des
années que j'appuie Barack Obama je suis
un fan vraiment je crois que c'est une
personnalité extraordinaire qui c'est un
phénomène assez rare dans dans
l'histoire politique je crois que son
timing est excellent il vient en moi je
suis ami avec John je suis pas d'accord
avec lui politiquement je suis également
copain avecro candidate mais j'appuie
plutôt bar merci beaucoup à tous les
deux et et on verra bien évidemment je
de dupe c'est donc à partir du mercredi
23 avril sur tous les écrans
merci voilà interview réalisée hier soir
dans ce studio de la musique maintenant